let's dive back into the mainstream
media the White House says President
Biden is fine tonight hours after he
tripped and fell during a graduation
ceremony at the Air Force Academy the
president is fine he's fine is the
president simply tripped Falls are
really common this is not some sort of
uh ominous Talisman about his medical
condition everything seems to be totally
fine uh just a misplaced sandbag we will
show you in the corner of a screen see
there's a sandbags and you know it's the
advanced team or whoever's fault that
they put a sandbag in front of it his
staff should uh you know make sure there
aren't obstacles like sandbags in his
way Twitter and the writer going crazy
it's currently dominating Fox News prime
time
tonight new questions about President
Trump's Health after this walk down a
ramp at West Point's Graduation Ceremony
this weekend his halting journey down a
ramp new questions about his health
where he cautiously descended a ramp the
nation in crisis and the president
tweeting about his walk down a ramp is
where we start today the President also
raised some questions during his West
Point speech after taking a moment to to
sip some water it was lacking the the
strength to raise the water glass there
he was the video's up now struggling he
takes one step with his left foot and
then the right foot comes and meets the
left foot well it's more than uh just
the way he walked Aaron he doesn't look
right this is not the first time the
president has had difficulty walking
down ramps his speech has become very
very slow as if he's struggling to read
from the teleprompter stumbled for
stumble Donald Trump seems to be right
in line with Joe Biden or in many ways
even worse when Biden Falls when Biden
slurs when Biden doesn't know where he
is when Biden has cue cards they run
cover for it or they ignore it all
together when Donald Trump walked slowly
down a ramp because the ramp was wet or
when he drank a glass of water with two
hands they were literally calling for
the 25th Amendment so that is
consistently what happens here but
anyway Biden did have that big fall on
Thursday and fortunately he is okay
right I do not want the president of the
United States to be incapacitated and I
certainly don't want it when you know
who the number two is
foreign
[Music]